wir hören dass die bundeskanzlerin in
internen sitzungen jetzt auch gestern
gesagt hat was sie davon ausgeht dass
diese mutation dieses sogenannte virus
dann bei 117 mutmaßlich ab nächsten
monat die stärkste variante sein wird
wenn es zu neuansteckungen kommt so und
da gibt es eine sorge und kanzleramt
jetzt kann man streiten ist die
begründet ist die nicht begründet aber
das ist zumindest das was die
bundeskanzlerin was ihren beraterstab
und was auch viele ministerpräsidenten
leitet und dann kommt so ein papier mehr
zustande wie ich jetzt gerade hoch
gehalten habe genau und es muss man
einfach ganz klar sagen der locker und
so wie wir ihn bisher kennen der geht
weiter mindestens bis 28 februar erster
märz vielleicht auch noch darüber hinaus
ein wichtiger punkt dann möchte ich hier
noch mal reinschauen sind die schulen
ein für mich sehr sehr wichtiges thema
schulen und kitas es hieß immer die
öffnen als erstes und jetzt ist es ja
auch sehr vage lass uns noch einmal in
diese grafik reinschauen formuliert denn
dort heißt es eine sichere und gerechte
öffnungs strategie für schulen und kitas
also auch das ist hier muss man ganz
klar sagen überhaupt gar kein ausblick
in eine konkrete öffnung hinein dass wir
eine sichere öffnungs strategie brauchen
auch das ist uns allen sicherlich seit
monaten klar absolut richtig patricia es
ist ja in den letzten tagen immer von
einer öffnungs perspektive gesprochen
worden die kanzlerin sollte dieses wort
in den mund genommen haben andere
länderchefs auch aber von dieser
öffnungs perspektive muss man sagen ist
jetzt in diesem papier zumindest das
insgesamt 16 punkte umfasst gar nicht
viel zu sehen es gibt zwei dinge die
darin interessanten du hast die schulen
angesprochen vollkommen richtig aber da
geht es ehrlich gesagt nur darum und das
ist auch noch nicht ganz konkret
formuliert wann man ab welche möglichen
incidents wird man in einen sogenannten
wechsel unterricht gehen kann es steht
noch mal drin man möchte die schule in
schrittweise wieder öffnen aber mehr ist
da auch nicht niedergeschrieben das
heißt es ist noch sehr unkonkret man
muss abwarten ob es vielleicht im
morgigen im zuge des neuen gipfels dann
konkreter wird aber da gibt es druck
einiger länder die möglichst schnell
auch öffnen wollen schrittweise an das
will das hätten die banken reagieren
ganz genau du hast es vollkommen richtig
gesagt er sachsen hat sogar ein
beschluss heute geht das kabinett das
eigentlich ab montag bereits schulen wie
mehr und mehr öffnen sollen da sind die
also deutlich schneller als der korona
gipfel morgen so und da muss man dann
sehen aber das ist bis jetzt hier
drinnen wirklich nur eine leichte
perspektive ein leichter silberstreif am
horizont das zweite um das es geht ist
das thema alten und pflegeheim auch da
gibt es nur eine leichte öffnungs
perspektive denn die bundeskanzlerin und
die ministerpräsidenten der länder
so steht es jetzt drinnen wollen den
bundesgesundheitsminister und die
gesundheitsminister der länder
auffordern eine strategie ein konzept zu
entwickeln wie denn wenn alle bewohner
von alten und pflegeheimen durchgetestet
sind die besucher regelungen die sehr
strikt sind beim etwas gelockert werden
können so aber auch das muss erst
erarbeitet werden und wir wissen so was
zu arbeiten dauert ein bisschen zeit das
dauert drei wochen dass dort vier wochen
da geht weitere zeit ins land also das
sind wirklich nur angedeutete öffnungs
perspektiven wenn man es einmal so
nennen kann